hey hey guys congratulations on this
show this is uh this is a wild one I'm a
big William Gibson fancy this is special
for me to watch uh Chloe I was wondering
from you you know when you got the
script and you first read it was it
something that you connected with and
understood right away or did you get a
couple passes at it to sort of grasp the
scope of the whole thing yeah well the
first meeting I had was they they did
they did not share the script with me
before the meeting so we know the the
meeting was was really just about uh the
book uh and and so I kind of did a deep
dive into the book and and and devoured
all that is uh the depth of William
Gibson and went into the meeting with
Lisa Jonah and obviously had so many
questions of how they were going to kind
of crack this open and and and you know
what was going to be there in on the
story
um and after our meeting you know
they've eventually shared the a couple
scripts with me and it was really clear
that you know this was different than
other sci-fi uh that I had seen kind of
make it to the screen before
um I think it really captured what I
loved about the book which is the
importance of Flynn and Burton's
relationship on screen and the warmth of
that and that no matter kind of how far
we get into uh the headiness of what
sci-fi can be
we always come back home and we know who
we're going to be trusting you know we
know who we can stand behind and I think
that that's something that we haven't
really seen in sci-fi before and it's
not so clinical it's not so uh you know
cold it's very warm that brother sister
Dynamic is really fantastic in this Jack
is there anything Chloe does that
reminds you of your own siblings
uh
I worked a little bit older than my
siblings
um but uh
no you know it's funny it's I think
we're just more similar to one another
really you know uh we kind of joke a
little bit about edit at times that you
know in our respective relationships
we're both the same person in the
relationships
um so you know it was really fun for us
honestly like when we both were attached
to the project I came on quite a bit
later actually because of the pandemic
but once we started to talk on FaceTime
you know we really hit it off right away
and we talked so much before we even met
each other that by the time we got
together in the room for the first time
I think everybody was quite surprised
that we hadn't already known each other
for years and that was really cool
um one thing that I really loved is the
way they treated the action in this show
and for both of you when you're when
you've got a career where you've had
experience doing action scenes fight
scenes or military scenes in the past is
it like a switch like do you know what
you're doing or what you're in for when
you get into a scene brand new or do you
have to train all over again
yeah I mean
I feel really lucky that I
you know obviously training train since
I was 10 years old
um and I kind of kept up with it
throughout the years and and have
implemented different forms of martial
arts throughout the years and kind of
changed my training as I've grown up
um so for me you know I feel like
choreography is kind of second hand and
I and I love doing choreography and I
pick up on it really really quickly
um and uh yeah you know it felt
wonderful to kind of literally Flex Flex
the muscles again and kind of get get
back into it
um and you know we had a really great
Sun team
we had two different Sun teams and the
sun team I worked with on my action was
a little bit different
um and it was just cool to see how they
implemented
um
a lot of a lot of Judo was implemented
into it which I think is fun for like a
small girl to be throwing a massive
massive guys over her shoulder
now aside from this I'm not sure if this
is the type of future I'd want to live
in but is there a TV or movie future
that you guys really love that's your
favorite
a TV or a movie future probably Back to
the Future too
sick
yeah I was gonna say I like rewards I
like Blade Runner but it's not the most
positive but it'd be cool it'd be safe
it'd be sick yeah
just another Blade Runner but with
hoverboards and yeah there you go that's
pretty good yeah
cheers thanks so much guys